ça ne m'inquiète pas trop de prendre une
pause depuis que je suis maire nous
avons eu trois années records de
croissance de la population et ça a été
très difficile de gérer ça techniquement
mais gérer l'extraordinaire croissance
comme vous avez dû faire pendant toutes
ces années ça a dû aussi présenté des
gros défi quand même ça padgett simple
et c'est difficile d'une manière comme
de l'ours rice et cet extrait difficile
vraiment qu'est ce qui était le plus
difficile c'était que 30 40 mille
personnes
ici chaque année 40 et c'est ça que tu
twittes richert la différence entre
25000 et 40000 personnes de plus par
année juste pour lui parce que tout le
monde veut de l'eau fraîche pour le
temps ça peut atteindre 250 millions de
dollars
alors mon travail est difficile mais
fantastique à travers tout ça vous avez
quand même été élu meilleur maire du
monde
alors quelle a été votre recette comment
vous avez fait ça parce que je suis sûr
qu'ils ont là quelques mères chez nous
qu'ils doivent écouter aujourd'hui je
n'ai aucune idée je suis un peu maniaque
je fouille je parle de politique qui je
me mets les pieds dans les plats
je n'aurais jamais cru que j'allais
embrasser des bébés et serrer des mains
mais je les fais je me fais prendre en
photo avec des adolescentes je ne
comprends pas comment tout ça est arrivé
je twitte je crois en quelque chose qui
n'est pas à la mode en politique
la politique c'est plus que de la coupe
politique c'est un service public
il faut être au service des gens
un million deux cent mille personnes
comptent sur moi j'essaie d'être très
honnête ni à droite ni à gauche
progressiste conservateur ou libéral
je ne sais même pas ce que ça veut dire
et je crois que la plupart des gens ne
savent pas ce que les gens veulent c'est
un gouvernement efficace
aujourd'hui je porte du rose parce que
c'est la journée contre les timides
mais en général je porte parce que c'est
du rouge et du bleu il ne faut pas
s'aliéner les gens en les classant dans
une catégorie ou une autre de nos jours
ce qui est populaire en politique c'est
de s'adresser à certains groupes envoyé
un message à certains groupes et ce
making prod rendre une décision calculé
froidement sur ce que vous allez dire
sur le niqab
parce que cela va déplaire à des gens
mais ça va plaire à d'autres c'est un
calcul
ce n'est pas ce que vous pensez du niqab
mais vous vous adressez au plus grand
nombre
je parle de moi une personne incluant
madame marois la charte des valeurs
phares de valeurs que moi je l'appelais
le char tourisme parce que cette chose
c'est à dire à quelques personnes qu'il
y a des jambes que vous ne pouvez pas
faire à cause de votre foi cause de
votre religion c'est pas mon canada
s'est pas manqué berck ou juste pour
clarifier les choses le parti québécois
disaient que tout le monde pouvait
travailler mais simplement ne pas porter
des signes religieux les laisser leurs
signes religieux chez eux et devenir
travailleuse chose de ridicule de dire
si vous êtes sic
vous ne pouvez pas laisser votre turban
à la maison vous n'avez pas le choix de
nos choix alors vous dites aux médecins
cycle puisque c'est un système public et
qu'il ne peut avoir une pratique privée
vous lui dites qu'il ne peut pas être
médecin c'est un incroyable gaspillage
de potentiel humain en terminant
mentionnons l'image qu'on se fait de
calgary ville de l'ouest
et pourtant calgary a élu le premier
maire musulman au canada alors qu'est ce
que ça nous dit de l'évolution de votre
ville
personne ne l'a remarqué
c'est ça qui compte le chapeau de
carbone va bien et je monte un cheval à
l'avant du défilé du samedi
mais après l'élection en 2010 on a
remarqué la cour
de ma peau et la religion les gens de
calgary se disait juste il est né dans
nord est de calgary c'est un des nôtres
on veut savoir ce qu'il pense du
transport en commun des taxes ou importe
où ils veulent vendredi soir avec elle
et sa foi je pense que c'est très
important pour comprendre l'ouest
canadien
c'est une force
je n'ai pas grandi en pensant que
certains métiers ne serait interdite à
cause de ma foi c'est très bien ainsi